well uh jalen green he is the
best dressed he is the flamboyant he is
the guy with the long hair
in the shiny suit and he went second
overall to the houston rockets history
repeating itself
1970. pistons and rockets had the first
and second selection
here's taylor rooks with the second pick
in the draft
jalen green all right jalen
congratulations you said it before the
draft you were going to go to one of
those top two teams how excited are you
that you landed in houston i'm super
excited i'm super sorry this is a dream
come true be top two
i'm leaving here happy yeah absolutely
now this is the thing about you
your confidence and your killer
mentality and one thing that you said
was that whoever passed up on you was
going to pay
so tell me send a message to all those
teams that do not have jaylen green in
their squad
um i'm sorry for y'all because i'm gonna
keep working i'm gonna keep getting
better every day i'm gonna keep
perfecting my craft
and every time i step on that floor it
detour especially so
i'm coming hey big talk all right you
said two of your goals this season were
to be rookie of the year and to land on
the all
defensive team how will you develop into
an elite two-way player
with the rockets um coach silas always
was talking about defense the whole time
and during the um
during my trip out there i'm just gonna
really lock in with him talk to him
and i'm gonna really focus on the
defensive side try to lock in all right
it's gonna be a joy to watch you
congratulations and welcome to the nba
jalen thank you i appreciate it
now just for those that are just tuning
in you coached him with the g-league
ignite can he win rookie of the year
because our poll says that he can
he definitely can um you know what he
did in the g league against the
competition
this year um averaging a little under 18
points a game
um the playoff game that we played
against toronto's team uh
he had 30 points they were double and
triple teaming them they had five
players on their roster that were nba
guys
i think that translates and is what
we're going to see
when you see the athleticism the
effortless
athleticism that he's going to bring to
the table and the highlights that he's
going to produce this year
he has a great chance of being rookie of
the year
i i love him i mean because he has a
flare b
shawl and a style that says come look at
me and when you say come look at me you
got to back it up and i've watched him
be shawn what i love about him is i love
his offense but what i love that you had
him doing
he took challenges defensively and i
think everybody keeps saying he's small
for his size but whenever you have a guy
that got a six eight
wingspan that's all i draymond green but
this is a guy that can
flat out fly you when you have long arms
you know
you can be a little bit small but when
you have a guy that can fly with long
arms and he has this
i want to be great usually those type of
guys going to give you
everything you got to tailor them down
i'm okay with telling the guy down be
sure
you know when i look at the lottery and
i know we're going to get to this but
i don't know if there's another player
that matches a team
where the player can basically do what
he did
the year before for you in the nba which
is
high volume shots because at houston
where it's a complete overhaul uh they
need someone to make shots
he can make shots uh i don't think they
will hold them back
whereas a lot of these other players
have to sort of fit into the system
or find their role i think he's the
perfect fit for houston here because
they need someone
like him who will be a stat stuffer
and he and he has a knack for figuring
it out on the fly
um there were times this year where he
had four points at halftime he come in
he said coach
what do you see what are they doing to
me i say jalen they're sitting on your
right hand so when they give you the
left
take it and he would go out and score 16
points in the third quarter
and he would figure it out he had a
knack for for being able to do that and
one thing you know he has a slender
wiry body one of the things he used to
say all the time was
i'm not backing down from any fades so
what you heard him say about
especially when we play detroit you guys
are going to see me on point because
he's really really mad that he wasn't
the first pick in the draft and that's
his mentality that he brings every day
he did not miss a single day of practice
a game
nobody beat him in a in a sprint
after practice when the team was running
and so and he's a student of the game on
on top of that so when you combine all
of those
different attributes and qualities that
he brings
you know he is absolutely going to be a
star in the nba
most important question who's going to
have the flashier suits
jaylen green or calvin murphy that's
what we need to know
i don't know if calvin's flashing
anymore they're different